the new aircraft carrier hms queen
elizabeth is to lead a strike force of
ships and planes around the world next
month
setting off from portsmouth in the uk's
largest signal of maritime and air power
in a generation let's speak now to
defence secretary ben wallace who's in
portsmouth
this morning good morning to you um i
want to come on to the
deployment in a moment but first of all
can i ask you about india
and what the the specific aid is that
that we're sending due to arrive
tomorrow yes
the united kingdom is going to send to
india oxygen compressors
and ventilators things that are are
really needed in the now as we've seen
from your own reports the pressure on
hospitals
in india is getting unbearable and you
know we're going to do our part to make
sure our friends
india get all the support they can we
obviously if you remember commissioned
huge numbers of ventilators to
alleviate the pressure on the hospitals
and it's only right that we share and
help them at their time in need
do you wish that the decision had been
taken sooner to provide this this aid
we know that they're sending 600 pieces
of medical equipment 495
oxygen uh concentrators but thousands
are
dying every day and we know that they're
dying in record numbers
well look this government alongside the
united states with the indian government
and
responding to their request that that's
the key to it is is that
it isn't like we just woke up this
morning and thought we'd do it it's been
properly worked out and planned with the
indian government
and made sure that it became available
as soon as soon as needed and you know
if necessary we'll put it in military
planes to get it there or charter other
planes
we'll do everything we can to make sure
we alleviate that suffering
will we be foregoing our vaccines from
india in order to to boost
their program and and will we be sending
vaccines and and test kits
well now first of all as your reports
show that the pressure at the moment
is in the hospital system and that's
where we're focusing our support and our
effort to make sure
that they help get through that on
vaccines obviously india itself is
manufacturing huge amounts of vaccines
it's got
millions and millions of doses and will
obviously be able to
roll itself through that program but
just if you remember if your viewers
cast their mind back
to our outbreaks and both the time of
the second and the first lockdown
this was about pressure on the nhs and
making sure that we the pipeline of
patients going into it
was managed because once the nhs or any
hospital system
gets overloaded you see what you see in
india and that's why we're helping
at that critical point in the process
both with the lessons that we have
learned but also with equipment that we
are no longer or not using or the
surplus
and sending it over to them back here
where we're reading this morning about
boris johnson allegedly saying that he'd
rather
see bodies pile higher in their
thousands than order a third
lockdown were you aware of of any such
comment and if
true i mean it's it's really shocking
isn't it but i i think i think look look
it's not true it's been categorically
denied by practically everyone
uh you know we're getting into the sort
of comedy chapter now of these gossip
and uh
stories and unnamed sources by unnamed
advisors talking about
unnamed events you know look i don't
none of this is is serious the prime
minister and as your viewers will know
has has been utterly focused on
delivering alongside cabinet colleagues
the response to covid whether that's
managing the hospitals and you know you
only have to look as you've just said
earlier
to what happens if that management gets
out of kilter in other countries and
then rolling out
the vaccine and you know today is really
good news over 62 percent of adults
in this country have a vaccine 62
over half the population have been
vaccinated we're way ahead of our
our contemporaries around the world and
that is a government-led rollout the
prime minister has been personally
engaged in it
and you know all the who said what said
what said you know i'll leave that to
the
oscar gossip columns that are now being
rolled out today after the night i'll
leave that to the hello magazines of the
world
uh but you know government is focused on
delivering for the viewer and the
citizen
a covered response you say that we're
getting into uh comedy territory and and
gossip columns but
uh i'll remind you of uh johnny mercer's
comments this is the veterans minister
uh who resigned uh some say sacked uh he
says that uh it's been the most awful
and distrustful environment to work in
uh almost nobody tells the truth um and
it's a cesspit
well uh johnny worked with me for uh
nearly two years in the department
you know he was a valued colleague uh
you know johnny has now left the
government he contributed to
to some of the policies towards helping
veterans he's campaigned
for veterans uh you know i campaigned
for my first veterans in 1998 so uh
he joins a large team of people doing
that campaign i i don't agree with any
of his observations about government
you know government is what you make of
it i i did every rank in government
before i became in the cabinet i was a
backbencher all the way through
the trick of being in government is
making sure that you focus and you
deliver
johnny did some really good work but you
know some of his comments i just don't
agree with
uh he does say that the government has
abandoned soldiers who served
in in the troubles he's actually in
belfast today
at a a trial um many would say
that he as a a veteran himself speaks
adequately
to that cause um what what do you say to
that criticism the government has
abandoned
these veterans well i think that's
wrong first of all the bill that johnny
started taking through parliament
is hopefully just about to complete
parliament this week another bill that
he started the armed forces bill and
which we
put in place in the law the armed forces
covenant the first government ever to
put that
covenant into the law or all the things
that he wanted that is
in process right now the simple fact is
if you want to help
veterans and you actually want to
deliver rather than just talk you need
to be in government
he was in government he did a brilliant
job we've got another new veterans
minister who's also a veteran serves in
afghanistan
was in the infantry he'll do a fantastic
job but fundamentally government does
the delivery
we've done that for overseas bills
that's the bill at the moment that will
protect
uh in future overseas deployments when
it comes to northern ireland veterans
i'm a northern ireland veteran i lost
soldiers in northern ireland
my soldiers some of them in similar
tours were convicted or put on trial for
events
i know exactly what it's like i know
right to the heart that community
we are committed to doing something for
them the government has said it i'm
convinced they are
and the northern ireland office
presented to johnny mercer and i only a
few weeks ago
some of their plans so we haven't
abandoned them we're going to deliver
and we're going to make sure we look
after our veterans
so you don't see it as embarrassing at
all that he's taking it upon himself
to be in belfast this morning to support
two veterans or on trial
i think it's embarrassing he's doing the
right thing in his eye i mean it's the
right thing to stand by people i don't
you know members of parliament regularly
attend and support their constituents
all their causes
he's doing what all member of parliament
does he's he's a he's a he's a very
doubty advocate of their cause you know
i'm a government minister i can't go and
prejudice a trial that would be
wholly wrong and i can't actually
comment on this trial and i think we
have to be
very very careful when there is ongoing
judicial proceedings as you yourself
will know
but you know look uh what is really key
and johnny has said this many many times
that uh you know if people break the law
no one is above the law in this country
whether they are soldiers or citizens no
one is that's the difference between us
and terrorists that's the difference
between us and some of those regimes
around the world
is we are not above the law but it is
perfectly right to make sure that when
people are investigated they're
investigated thoroughly
but not repeatedly and also when people
are sued by lawyers
who are seeking the money like phil
shiner if you remember from public
interest money
rather than actually seeking uh what
they would view as justice it's really
right we make steps to prevent that
happening that's what we're doing
at the moment johnny is continuing his
campaign and i i wish him all the very
best
uh let's talk about your announcement uh
today uh the carrier going to the
indo-pacific
region tell us about that
well i'm standing in front of a 65 000
ton ship
made in six united kingdom shipyards
with amazing skills
going into it it's it's the first fifth
generation
aircraft carrier of its type in nato
it's going to travel 26 000 miles to
japan
and back it's going to carry 3 000 plus
people
aircraft partly made in lancashire in my
own part of the world
and it is about projecting global
britain it's about saying
first of all that britain has this
capability back we all remember the ark
royal and
all those other aircraft carriers we had
it's about our place in the world
and making sure we're an anchor in nato
providing protection from
aggressive actions by our adversaries
and it's also about going across the
world to uphold things like the
international
rule of the sea the un convention of of
the sea and making sure that our allies
globally know that we're there in spirit
uh and
in physical power should they need it uh
one of the areas heading to
obviously will be china is it
appropriate to be
heading to china at this time
well we're heading to japan and we will
obviously transit through
the likes of the south china sea and
getting there but you know britain's
deployment is not to be provocative
britain's deployment is to go and
show show common value and uphold those
laws
that are sometimes threatened by a whole
range of people terrorists and other
uh sometimes more aggressive nations and
to go out there around the world
and show solidarity with australia and
new zealand but also to celebrate
something that most people don't really
know about but 50 years
this year ago 50 years ago the five
power
defense agreement came into being that
was new zealand australia malaysia
singapore and the united kingdom it's
the oldest
defense uh cooperation agreement uh in
the pacific and we're going over there
to celebrate that as well because that's
really really important that's long
before the current challenges and
instability
it goes right back and uh you know
that's why this ship is really important
she
she's you know she we should be proud of
her she's british and
and i'm proud that what we're going to
stand for is all those values of freedom
and the rule of law
but minister is it is it about a show of
power though
it's about lots of things so this ship
does everything it is it's not just a
hard military
piece of equipment it's a it's a
national convener we'll have united
states
aircraft on board will be accompanied by
a dutch frigate around the world we're
going to meet up with the french
charles de gaulle carrier in the
mediterranean it's a great convener
it's also a great show of british
capability and engineering and when we
go to places like
india and other countries on the route
it'll be about saying you know this is
what britain can do
this is what we can do together we'll
convene people along trade we'll convene
people in culture we'll convene decision
makers and all those countries to make
sure that you know britain
and those countries recognize that the
most important thing we have that some
of our adversaries don't have
we have alliances we have friends and we
have a mutual
uh belief in the values of democracy and
the rule of law and that's what we're
there
to do having a carrier is a really
important part of a tier one military
power
uh we we haven't had it for a few years
and i'm incredibly proud that it's now
ready to go and it will be setting sail
soon
next month ben wallace secretary of
state for defence thank you